economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio de daniela hablando con daniela
buena noche bienvenida le pregunto cómo
se comportaron los mercados
internacionales hoy después de conocerse
que donald trump contrajo el coi 19 el
coronavirus raúl muy buenas noches pues
mire la incertidumbre política que
genera esta noticia a tan solo un mes de
elecciones sin duda movió los mercados
aunque no como si hubiera esperado el
más afectado fue el petróleo cuyo precio
cayó alrededor del 4 por ciento tanto en
la referencia de w como el brent de
europa walk se revirtió dos sesiones
consecutivas al alza y reaccionó
modestamente a la baja mientras tanto
por el contrario las plazas bursátiles
europeas parecen haber sobrevivido a la
noticia las que no subieron ligeramente
tuvieron caídas leves el presidente ha
causado más de preocupación en la semana
en américa latina la que más se dejó
contagiar fue la bolsa de sao paulo un
analista explica esta reacción en las
bolsas del mundo
el momento determina porque el mercado
no está respondiendo tan negativamente
como podría haberlo hecho si el
presidente hubiera contraído el virus
desde el principio simplemente se habría
sumado a la incertidumbre y el miedo que
rodea al virus
creo que los inversionistas se centrarán
más en la recuperación de la economía
como el informe laboral de septiembre
daniela propósito de empleo los
demócratas insisten en aprobar un
paquete de estímulos al que la casa
blanca supone si la cámara baja aprobó
un paquete de 22 billones de dólares que
muy seguramente no pasará en el senado
porque la casa blanca se opone esta
semana ha habido varios acercamientos
pero los republicanos han cedido no han
cedido e incluso algunos demócratas le
dieron la espalda a su propio partido en
medio de este panorama hoy se conoció
que el desempleo bajó al 7.9 por ciento
en septiembre esta cifra confirma una
mejoría mes a mes desde que se disparó
al 14,7 por ciento en abril cuando fue
la tasa más alta desde la gran depresión
la mala noticia raúl
la creación de empleos se sigue
desacelerando con fuerza en septiembre
fue de apenas 600 61 mil cuando los
meses anteriores había sido mucho más
alta se estima que hasta el momento se
ha recuperado apenas de la mitad de los
más de 20 millones de plazas laborales
perdidas durante la pandemia y concluyó
este viernes en la novena ronda de
negociaciones del brics y daniela como
concluyó bueno los negociadores
reconocieron que todavía hay serias
divergencias sobre todo en el tema de la
pesca todavía quedan unos días para que
haya consenso
i'm staying en estos tiempos de ccoo y
19 con un impacto devastador en las
economías es bueno tener un acuerdo pero
no a cualquier precio principalmente el
tema de igualdad de condiciones cómo
podemos asegurarnos de que exista entre
ambas economías y la cuestión de la
pesca es muy difícil así que veremos
cómo avanzamos en eso
ribolzi week pro gastón tal el primer
ministro británico boris johnson puso
como fecha límite la mitad de octubre si
para ese entonces no están de acuerdo la
regla
entre reino unido y la unión europea
podría dejar de ser tan amigable
friends espero que consigamos un trato
depende de nuestros amigos ahí estamos
ellos han hecho un trato como el que
queremos con canadá que están muy lejos
porque no pueden hacerlo con nosotros
estamos tan cerca hemos sido miembros
del bloque durante 45 años
todo está ahí solo depende de ellos
daniela cambio más información vengamos
a nuestro continente específicamente
américa del sur porque argentina lanzó
un plan económico para ahorrar divisas
sino lo que hará es reducir la cuota que
deben pagar por derechos de exportación
los productores de soja y sus
principales derivados esto también
aplica para otros bienes industriales el
objetivo es que los sectores que puedan
exportar tengan un incentivo para
reducir las importaciones de esta manera
raúl se podrán ahorrar divisas que por
estos días han estado bastante esquivas
en este país suramericano otros sectores
que según el gobierno van a tener
estímulos a la exportación
vinos petróleo y gas y calzado entre
otros
para finalizar daniela que nos trae hoy
como cifra el día 403 de millones de
dólares en esta cifra está valorada la
fusión de playboy enterprises con la
firma monte inglés por medio de este
acuerdo la famosa empresa del fallecido
hugh hefner regresar a wall street tras
nueve años de ausencia ahí tiene para
que invierta la baja así es daniela
muchísimas gracias entonces por toda la
información económica ustedes también
gracias continúen con nosotros
y